[Musique]
quand tout va représenter la martinique
à l'élection miss france
tout d'abord c'est de la détermination
de la motivation parce que on y va c'est
pour gagner c'est pour remporter le
titre mais a aussi un peu d'appréhension
et de peur et d'excitation mais je
dirais que l'excitation prend le dessus
parce que j'ai vraiment envie de voir
comment la ventura s'est déroulé j'ai
envie qu'elle débute de rencontrer les
autres candidates
et puis aussi de connaître l'issue
du jour au lendemain ça a été un honneur
pour moi de savoir que j'étais que je
prenais le relais et que je représentais
la martinique à l'élection miss france
donc ça a été d'abord de la fierté de la
surprise beaucoup de surprises et aussi
de joie parce que je suis très fier de
pouvoir représenter mon pays mon pays
que j'aime tant cette année à l'élection
[Musique]
lorsqu'on a envie de décrocher la
couronne et le titre miss france il est
vrai qu'il faut se préparer avec
beaucoup d'un avec beaucoup d'attention
et alors cela passe par des cours de
communication des cours d'expression
et puis des cours de sport des cours
aussi de développement personnel de
coaching mental j'espère avoir tout en
tout cas je me donne les moyens pour
tout avoir mais jusqu'à présent les
choses se passent bien et j'espère que
la préparation que j'ai eu en amont me
permettra plus amplement d'aller vers
mon objectif est de revenir avec le
titre